on Friday night this friday night i was
coming out of
drugstore and a father
is probably three or four year old child
or on their way in and I overheard just
a moment of their conversation like you
do sometimes going in or out of
someplace and I didn't notice but I saw
later that there was a large red and
white banner in front of the store that
said flu shots every day and the little
child must have asked about it because
as I was going out the father was saying
it means you can get a flu shot every
day and there was a brief pause and then
the father asked do you want to get a
flu shot and there was another long
pause from this little red-haired child
when the child looked up item with these
big eyes and said loudly with I think a
tinge of terror I don't want to get a
flu shot every day
if we hear the words of our epistle
lesson today we might experience a
similar terror if we're honest because
the author writes first of all then I
urge supplications and prayers
intercessions and Thanksgivings be made
for everyone everyone really should
there be a blue and white banner hanging
outside battelle chapel that says
prayers offered here for everyone every
day could we live up to it we might
respond like that child I don't want to
pray for everyone because in the end we
don't we don't want to pray for everyone
we don't want to pray for the people who
annoy us I'm sure you have some in your
life the unreasonable co-worker the
snotty clerk in the store the jerk down
the hall who plays ear-splitting music
at three o'clock in the morning and
those are just the easy ones because
then we go up a level because we don't
want to pray for the people who have
heard us people who have rejected us
abused us or ignored us people who've
talked us down we don't want to pray for
the ex-boyfriend or the ex-wife the
woman whose politics require that she
argue against my equal rights the
professor who makes the seemingly funny
but ultimately nasty remarks we don't
want to pray for them much either and
even more we don't want to pray for the
really hard ones the people who seem to
have done unforgivable things violence
against the innocent genocide hate
mongering the legends but the words
still hang on the page there are first
Timothy first of all them I urge that
supplications prayers intercessions and
Thanksgivings be made for everyone and
the author of the letter to Timothy goes
on to an even more outrageous statement
to back this up he says this is right
and is acceptable in the sight of God
our Savior
who desires everyone to be saved and to
come to the knowledge of the truth God
wants everyone to be saved even Hitler
even the man being tried at the New
Haven courthouse right now even sarah
palin if you're liberal even Barack
Obama if you're a tea partier I remember
a good Christian friend who seed
literally seed four weeks after a
particularly nasty election in which the
candidate he supported was defeated by
less than honorable tactics it was
Chicago and every day we he would come
to work with me and he would wave the
newspaper at me and point and yell about
today's rat new revelations of the dirty
tricks and the corruptions of the
winners and then one day he stopped I
didn't even notice cuz you don't notice
that kind of thing but a couple of days
later I asked him are you okay with this
now and he said i was giving those jerks
too much power over me they were messing
up my life so now i'm praying for them
if i had a title for the sermon i think
it would be praying for jerks because
what often stands between me and praying
for those who annoy me those who have
hurt me those who I even hate or fear is
power they have a power over me when I
think of them I react without thinking
without choosing I have lit a literal
gut reaction and I can't think straight
and sometimes I have fantasies of
revenge or comeuppance that don't fit
with what I really believe about the
world but they're still there but what
st. Paul writes to poor young Timothy
who Paul left behind in Ephesus to try
to clean up an internal church battle
what's a Paul writes to him is that he
is given power over this situation
because he can pray it's not political
or emotional power but a kind of
virtual power we see it at those
critical moments in Jesus's life when
the storm clouds are gathering and Jesus
hikes out into the wilderness to be with
God it's a power over situations that
says there are forces bigger than me and
bigger than you my enemy there are
forces that encompass us both and though
you make me absolutely crazy sometimes I
can believe that God desires you even
you and me should be saved for 1st
Timothy goes on to write for there is
one God and there is also one mediator
between God and humankind Christ Jesus
himself human who gave himself a ransom
for all you noticed that word keeps
coming up it's all about all it's all
about everyone now this might seem cheap
and easy just think nice Christian
thoughts about people who make your
blood boil and all will become calm and
peaceful right mmm that's not the way it
works but say Paul as we know from his
letters can be warm and kind on occasion
but when he's in a church crisis he can
be as political as any party whip and as
tough as nails he's not saying be nice
he believes that in praying for all
people we gain power I was taught that
prayer was all sweetness and kindness
and heavenly thoughts but st. Paul is
saying pray as a survival tool pray to
change yourself and your relationship
with others because praying for all even
those with power over us puts us and
them in perspective because there's only
one God and one mediator Jesus Christ
who gave himself for all and when others
claimed power over me it sometimes real
and sometimes not and sometimes it's
just the power I give them over me but
even when they have real power over me
it's not ultimate power there is only
one God and when I am unable or afraid
to pray for other people then I give
them godlike power over me so I should
pray but should I pray so that I feel
powerful
over my enemies no prey to reassert what
we know to be true that there is one God
who loves all and desires all to be
saved including me you don't have to
pray that God will shower puppies and
lollipops down on your enemies evil is
not overcome by niceness but spiritually
I find solid ground when I step out of
living in a world where my sense of self
is continually in danger from other
people and step into a world where I'm
loved by a God who loves my enemies no
less now some of you may be thinking now
hold on just a second what do you say
about God desiring that all people
should be saved it's not me its first
Timothy all people self what the Bible
says there are many Bible passages that
say we should love others but often when
you boil down the context of the passage
they're really talking about loving
others within the church and this is one
scripture among others that go seem to
go further and seem to say that God
wants to save all people and Jesus is a
mediator with God for all people and the
all people really seems to mean all but
there are also many many Bible passages
that say that some will be saved and
some will not be and I'm not going to
resolve that in the next minute but for
this situation Timothy faced a group of
church leaders who believed that they
and their small group of followers were
the real Christians never happens in our
church they believed that they were the
real Christians and everyone else was
not so st. Paul is reminding Timothy
that no matter how eloquent or powerful
or persuasive those enemies seemed that
there were not to God's one for the
spiritual elite and one for everybody
else even Timothy young and timid and
alone in Ephesus had the same right to
argue the truth as the elders and sages
of Ephesus I don't know if you ever
catch yourself but I do sometimes bowing
to the most assertive Christian voice in
the room
who ever seems to feel the strongest
about what they believe I sit okay yeah
sure sometimes I hear you saying here in
this church that whatever the popular
view of what Christianity says is well
that's what Christianity says right but
when you dive deep into the scriptures
and the rich history of Christian
thought you find many different voices
there are historical streams influenced
by Greek philosophy or historical
moments in Syria many different
influences and they aren't all of equal
strength and coherence and some wander
too far from Jesus in the scriptures but
the vehemence with which they are
asserted isn't equal to their truth and
at a time when strange things are being
said about God and our nation and
Christian values it's good to demystify
anytime someone says well real
Christians believe this Jesus had a way
of testing ideas about God he looked at
his opponents behavior and said you say
you believe this but what you actually
do says the opposite I think st. Paul is
pointing us in the same direction if I
can live as though no one has ultimate
power over me not decision-makers not
those who have hurt me not professors
not my political enemies then I assert
that God is ultimately God no human
being has that power over me they can
and sometimes do hurt me test me reject
me but they cannot be my god so whatever
I come to believe about who will be
saved and how I begin by praying for all
of them not just some not just the
people I like not just people like me
not just the people who believe the same
things I do not just Americans not just
Christians anthropologists say that
human beings are tribal by nature that
if you test people their circle of
friends and family and connections I
mean real friends not Facebook friends
is almost always about 100 to 150 people
this is your tribe these are the people
that are important to you but Jesus
especially described as Saint Luke
always seems to be asking us to extend
our tribe a little further
that person who seems another is the one
Jesus wants us to let into our circle
the criminal the Samaritan the tax
collector the notorious sinner my
picture of Jesus is as a very bad head
waiter in a restaurant he's always
coming back to your table to say I saved
that little extra space over there do
you mind if this stranger comes in and
sits down with you could you squeeze one
more in on your bench and perhaps that's
how Jesus mediates for all can I picture
Jesus wandering the wedding feast in
heaven saying to a crowded table could
you scoot over a little my friend Ian
here has shown up a little late we
weren't sure he was going to make it
could you make room